Suge knight gear for La.
Did you hear a lot about that?
Utuber what he's going through?
Logan.
Paul.
I did read that.
Yeah.
He,
he films someone who had committed suicide in Japan and he put it on his youtube
channel.
Yeah,
I guess there's this forest at the,
the bottom of a volcano or something and it's called suicide,
her,
its nickname suicide forest because everyone just goes her to commit suicide.
And he was going there supposedly to film how it's haunted and then they find a
body and it's pretty gross.
How He,
you know,
how the video,
he was a,
he kind of joked about it.
He used humor.
Jamie told me that like the thumbnail had him like posing with the guy,
you know,
in the background and,
and you know,
he's,
um,
I don't know anything about him,
but I know he's a youtube guy.
Right.
And he's doing stuff that he thinks is interesting and provocative,
you know,
and for whatever reason,
the,
the dialogue that I've read was something to the likes of that he had done it to
bring,
he'll apologize for it,
which seemed obviously felt terrible about the way people viewed it,
but that he said that,
um,
how did he describe it?
Um,
he was trying to bring some sort of a,
he thought he was going to bring some sort of an awareness to suicide,
but it was like a clunky,
you just didn't do it right and prayed the respect that it deserved.
He realized that he fucked up.
He's basically saying he's trying to do something and you fucked up,
you know?
I don't know man.
It's pretty great.
I just found out that he's not the same.
Like there's a Jake Paul and a look and Paul,
I thought they were the same person.
Why blood?
Why is everyone mad?
I don't know what anyone's mad at him for the mad at him because he showed you
something you didn't want to see.
Is that what it is?
Because the video,
he kind of like,
they were like,
look at his hands,
they're blue and oh,
he kind of was very poor taste.
He also advertised it like the day before,
like I had this crazy sick video you guys are going to freak out about and you
should act like that.
Oh,
so he got a chance to look at it and he still approved it and then released it.
Yeah.
And then he made a thumbnail where it looked like he posed for like photos with
a guy in the background.
It's a very,
you know,
this was a person and,
and they're like laughing right next to his body.
You know,
it's,
but I dunno how that disturbs the shit out of us.
Right.
Like make it like joking around.
You could joke around,
but you can't joke around near a dead guy.
Well,
suicides not funny.
So it's not,
if the guy died,
natural causes,
no one's laughing.
Yeah,
the suicide,
the laughing at him,
joking around near the guy who committed suicide.
Like I'm not saying you should do it.
He definitely shouldn't.
I don't want to see it.
But it's kind of funny that we like decide,
like you said,
just respectful bro.
But he didn't really do anything.
He just showed up and this guy was dead.
You know?
I'm not saying he should make fun of him.
He definitely shouldn't,
but it's,
it's weird the outrage that we have for it.
I'm sure he made a shitload of money that,
cause I've got 7 million viewers.
He made money off it as suicide.
Yeah.
And you're talking about when we're talking about we're helping them out.
Well,
the video got pulled.
I guess I've got re uploaded a few times.
Yeah.
He just made a second apology today because the first apology a lot of people
said was very insensitive.
I'm not defending him.
Don't,
don't get me wrong.
I'm just explore.
Look,
sometimes I try to look at things from as many perspectives as I can,
and I don't,
I don't,
uh,
I don't think that you ever want to make fun of someone dying.
Right.
When you're right there and you're,
you're,
you're taking videos and you know,
it was a dead body hanging.
That's a terrible idea.